The joe rogan experience,
but we are in the,
you know,
but also no know shut up.
Right.
But it's also people on both ends.
Like you choosing to get upset about
some really ridiculous Sheree the tweet
and you go to that person's page and you
go,
I get it.
Read someone's tweet and I go to that
main page.
I could put,
I could add up right in one minute.
I get it.
I get where he was coming from.
I understand why he said that.
He's a musician.
He's daddy's a politician.
He sells this,
he likes to to this today somebody hit
me and I ran.
He was a poor riser fan.
I get it.
You're a fucking book.
You know what I'm saying?
I've never met a Paul Riser Fan of your
Paul Riser fashion.
Shoot yourself in the fucking mouth
right now.
Once somebody said,
if I go to some of these pains and I see
like music and I know the music sucks,
that's where it ends.
Because of his choice of music sucks.
That's what if I don't see you fucking
one of my three on there,
like I'm gonna go on to people's that
there's two things I judge people don't
judge people by money or nothing.
I just people that music collection.
But I look at your collection.
You don't have sabbath paranoid if you
don't have the staples Zeplin too.
Those are the stable.
If you don't have a Zeppelin to,
why are we here?
Why Not Smoking Dope for you?
Why are you wasting my fucking time?
I'm over here.
You got like Judy granted.
You know what I'm saying?
That and number two,
when you opened up some of these
refrigerators,
there's certain,
yeah,
it's true.
You'll open that tells me everything.
If you're a fucking milk,
if you're a month,
if I see like low and beer,
your fucking money.
I ain't never come in here.
And I did certain people that um,
they have music laying around just
because it's cool.
I'm tons of them.
That's why the generation of people that
want to say,
and I know this and I don't hate you
cause I'm kind of in the same way that
they don't want to like Floyd's they
prefer to listen to.
Oh that's so commercialize.
Yeah.
Into more receipt.
You know,
they make you feel bad.
The worst being that Tom Waits era,
those motherfuckers are ones I want to
punch him right in the fucking face
because they're the ones you're having a
good time listening to something.
You're Bob and they want to like really
impressed,
like some fucking dumped chick with
freckles or something.
Everybody's fucked already gone.
You know what I'm saying?
Everybody fucked.
All you need is Tequila and a grammar
blown.
She'll be sucking your dick in the
fucking bathroom.
You want to be cool.
And let's the Tom waits heavy winds of
time.
Wait,
that's good singing.
You want that,
you're fucking idiot.
But the only reason that people would
put that shit on is to try to overpower
you with that fucking star wars.
What do you call that?
The fucking thing with the mind.
The mind.
That's it.
Oh,
he's so,
oh my God,
he likes Tom.
Wait,
listen to this and they're trying to let
me sit you down with a gun next to your
head.
You're telling me that's good.
That's good.
That's the Beatles.
Y'All fucking shoot.
You fucking put a gun to your fucking
hat.
All right,
telling me that's good music.
You're fucking 20 years old.
Knock it off.
Like when somebody says,
I like the Dave Matthews band.
I will pistol whip you.
I'm the way up here.
But you would access this to me.
That would do an exodus by bucking Bob
Marley.
I almost cracked the fucking car.
A white dude with no shoes on and a
black new planner.
It fucking,
it's too,
it's true.
Made up uncle Joey stop it.
I think he's got some good songs.
They bath.
It's got a few good.
So you got me emotional.
Thank God I've got together.
Fuck this shit.
I was too quiet over there.
I hate all that shit.
Just listen.
You don't like it.
Just move over.
I can't stand fucking time.
And the people like Tom Waits,
look at them and go to that page and
it'll tell you the whole thing like
that.
That something ain't right.
That vegans something there,
you know,
stopped the pill.
Could pilgrims they care for something
that you're like,
really?
I was like,
the Tom Waits is a guy who probably has
a son that I would like,
but I don't want to go find it.
Oh,
he's probably like one or two songs.
One Song,
pick a fucking song,
pick a song.
And it sounds like he's taking a shit.
It sounds like a dude.
What the fuck is this?
More on singing and I know people going,
oh my God,
he's a revolution than I know Paul
Mccartney.
He's a bad motherfucker.
Why?
He's alive.
Everybody else was dead.
Paul Mccartney won this war.
It's true.
George Harrison's dead.
Everybody's dead.
Michael Jackson's dead.
Paul Mccartney still,
even his wife,
he killed the fucking,
blew the Lipton chick.
What did her parents,
old fucking Kodak.
She had debt.
Guma.
He moved to,
he didn't know he drove her to get a
fucking sandwich.
He died in the car.
Remember dog?
Nobody fucking,
then he had the one with the missing
leg.
Courtney lives McCarthy one.
This fucking game.
We beat you out one.
Everybody McCartney outlived everybody.
The only one him out in John Ball.
We Mick Jagger,
which you don't even want to fuck with
all those other guys.
Think Mick Jagger said filter
motherfucker.
Dude,
ain't God.
I hate that motherfucker.
Why did they hit you want to just
wrangle Mick Jagger?
Why Mick Jagger's or different dudes?
You know Mick Jagger comes up.
Mick Jagger.
What was his background?
I don't know.
Like look at his background.
His background is like,
he went to like the best business
school.
Did you know that?
Really?
Yeah.
In England.
Like he's like a fucking wizard
economist or something.
This story.
Yeah.
He don't do nothing unless you show up
with a big bag book.
I know in Boulder,
like we talked about this in the podcast
one time in boulder,
you know out unconscious,
the seats behind you.
Shallow what?
Mr Jagger,
nobody sells the tickets behind them.
They won't bump.
I'm Mick Jagger,
so those tickets,
so we don't go onstage heard that new
shit.
It's horrible.
It's not that bad.
That new songs.
Not that really.
It's not that bad.
I don't know.
I just think that,
let me see what I can find it.
Let's help them.
Let's promote the rolling stones.
How funny is that?
Yeah.
It will help you out.
Rolling Stones.
I know you need this.
You never read the little podcast.
He's got a book.
He's got a book that somebody wrote
about them and they interview somebody.
Who's the chick that saying,
you know your soul vain.
Carly Simon.
Carly Simon sat next to,
she was awesome at some movie premiere.
Awesome.
Mick Jagger sat next to him.
I was like,
Oh,
you got a joint?
No,
you got to [inaudible] got a bump of
coke.
No.
How about a blow job jacket just killed.
How do you know if he really
talk?
This guy married his wife and he married
in the country.
We're fucking,
it wasn't even legal to be married.
This guy one step ahead of the game.
All he gives a fuck.
It's getting his dick suck.
He's 60 something.
You think Stallone shooting shit.
This guy,
oh,
Smith's lapse alone is Dick.
This guy shooting everything
you ready to?
Of course record.
Oh,
it is already.
What the fuck's on?